hey there Bo how was your weekend well
actually I got a little sick oh really
I'm sorry to hear that man yeah Bullets
Over Broadway was on TV I came down with
a big old Diane whis
infection like
yeast hey takey the place on the corner
is serving lemonade and you get to keep
the jar it's pretty cool yes that's very
cool Scully mm will you excuse me just
one moment oh sure guys guys guys Scully
has a mason jar full of lemonade you
called us in here to tell us that no I
called you in here to change your lives
for you see a mere 5 minutes ago
Hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in an identical mason
jar oh this isn't going to end well
there are two possible outcomes and
we're going to bet on which one happens
first so will Hitchcock put fish food in
scully's lemonade or will Scully drink
Hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
Hitchcock just drank his own fish what
no wait for it wait for it 9:01 Amy
Santiago is officially late for the
first time ever all right let's do this
who's got theories uh alarm didn't go
off all three alarms all with battery
backup come on who wants to take this
seriously o she was taken in her sleep
that's that's what I'm talking about
super dark boil but way more plausible
than the Serge's idiotic alarm clock
Theory I bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9:00 a.m. why is no one
working Amy Santiago is a few minutes
late and we're all trying to guess why I
like to
play I'd say she's in line at the
bank this is fun it is fun but you're
all wrong she clearly slipped through a
Subway way grade and is having terrible
sex with a
molean there she is Amy where have you
been we've been worried sick do you care
to explain yourself I'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it Santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us
now there was a problem at the bank God
damn hey everyone sorry I'm late so
what's this secret meeting all about you
guys know I'm not medically cleared for
another week it's not a secret meeting
Jake it's an intervention the tips have
to go what why Jake we're worried about
you and you look very stupid come on
guys I think they're kind of cool retro
no they're terrible Amy come on you're
digging the tips right no I feel like
I'm kissing Vanilla Ice there was a time
you would have jumped at that chance
they have to go all right you guys got
me I did it as a joke I kept them
ironically pretty funny right I'm just
going to head out get him yeah get
yes
Terry okay okay wait wait okay okay okay
stop stop stop stop I'll admit it I went
too deep down there in
Florida at one point I think I forgot
where the tip of me ended and the base
of the tips began before we just chop
them off would anybody like to say some
final words no that was one word that
counts thank you Rosa okay I'm ready
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it me and Jake are tip buds
what
[Applause]
[Music]
no you know what I do see it it's bad it
looks
bad Jake hurry up I'm starving sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry I just had to
grab my
wall
gentleman
fine I was trying something and it
didn't
work hey Charles want to grab a beer
before you go home oo a yeast Feast
never mind no no no I want to go it's
just there's a huge emergency I have to
deal with first oh no is everything okay
it's about my food truck I have to get a
parking spot oh that doesn't sound as
intense as you were making it out to be
move your ass you old what is
happening we have to get there by 7:00
when they lift the parking restrictions
it's the best spot in Brooklyn and
everyone wants it get the hell out of
the way
Charles I highly doubt the entire food
truck industry is racing to get into
this one spot it's not Mad Max we're
neck and neck with rice pudding you got
Korean Tacos on your six oh my God it's
real we're on the Fury Road witness me
blood bear hold on
[Applause]
[Music]
t
good morning boy it's
Halloween I'm surprised you didn't put
on a costume I was going to sir but then
I decided screw that jazz well I'm the
only one who ever dresses up no one ever
gets my costume and they make fun of me
so I'm done these people don't deserve
my dress up
gifts Charles seriously no costume what
the hell Charles where's your Halloween
spirit but you guys always make fun of
me I have never once insulted you in my
life especially Visa your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person Andor thing yes I do remember sir
permission to Sprint to my car and get
my emergency costume doesn't matter if I
say no
[Music]
no bam bam
boom what the what why are you dressed
up you look like an idiot but yeah what
are you supposed to be a sassy car
mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected Pop-Tarts mascot Harry
Pop-Tarts I am not you know who I am
Squad that's enough you're making boil
for bat on purpose he's Elvis yes Elvis
sto the Canadian figure skater
no can you believe this Scully looks
like we're the only responsible people
who show up on time anymore and they're
always calling us lazy but where are
they now I don't see them they're not
here but you know who is hcin Scully the
oos the H H the idiots what are you
doing here the building's being
fumigated there were so many emails
there were we
didn't lightweight that's your
[Music]
takeaway it's happening again Rosa Rosa
Hitchcock fell asleep in the break room
I pranked him I tied his shoelaces
together you're 38 years old dude I know
and yet my pranks still stay so fresh
it's incredible got to untie his shoes
before he gets hurt seriously seriously
seriously fine but what's the worst
thing that could happen he's being
strangled death
how cluck cluck gobble gobble guess who
just came from the ps321 Thanksgiving
Parade Charles you actually Charles I'm
Tommy gobbler and I'm stopped with
Thanksgiving happiness a gobble Goble
seriously Char I warned you I'm Tommy
gobbler you silly Pilgrim okay Tommy
gobler there you go these are the
Davidsons they want to know what
happened to their missing
grandmother I have some deeply tragic
news for
you heads up there's our per looking all
pery just pering his way down per Street
take a picture give me one second this
light is really un flattering for his
complexion it doesn't have to be perfect
Tom Olson is a bad dude he's held up
four electronic stores at gunpoint man I
wish you hadn't read that Annie leitz
book quit calling it a book it was a
visual Journey you probably think I
should shoot this in color instead a
black and white yes shoot color why have
you been shooting black and white
where's he going now come
on damn it need
freeze he's trapped top of car foot
chase my birthday wish finally came
[Music]
true keep it up he's yours he's yours
he's yours I know I feel like the
coolest person in New York
[Applause]
City
bottles boil Bullpen what are you
bottles boil Bullpen bowling behold
Brooklyn buddies boil Bullpen bottle
bowling beautiful be brave bro be brave
[Music]
Bowl
damn bull booah
[Applause]
[Music]
babush are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepper
smort excuse me you need to watch
yourself I'm sorry cop all right let's
everybody just stay calm here oh what
are you going to arrest me for dancing
you call that
dancing this is
dancing what is happening I'm diffusing
a
situation dancing happened must capture
image of a
lifetime why is my phone always dead I
paid $13 for it don't worry Jak I got it
okay no my hands are covered in butter
from making butter I'm on it must record
must record camera on all right here we
go dancing over situation diffused
[Music]
no